since we last saw you Emma Stone on the
show you wouldn't want an Oscar well
done you there's you know often people
in this piece you know I never dreamt of
this moment but you did more than dream
of this moment I mean you planned this
it wasn't that specific should be fair
no I mean what you mean just like in
terms of my childhood yes when you when
you dream when you made your pitch to
your parents yes
I've this is this story will never die
well I will reread did it cuz I was easy
I was 14 I was almost 15 and I made a
PowerPoint presentation for my parents
and they didn't want you to go they
weren't gonna let you move is that it
well no they did they hadn't even heard
the idea yet it was just like I realize
if I'm gonna you know I lived about a
six-hour drive from from LA in Phoenix
Arizona and I realized I couldn't just
come home in my freshman year of high
school which is what grade nine ninth
grade okay
oh and I realize I couldn't just walk in
and go like I'm moving here I go so I
decided to make a PowerPoint
presentation about why it would be a
good idea for me to follow my big dreams
but you went to RIT like it had music
and everything yeah it had this song
Hollywood by Madonna
sensible pants I should have been in a
sense of I think I was in my like high
school I went to an all-girls Catholic
high school so I think I was in like a
plaid skirt and a collared shirt and so
so Madonna Madonna's playing and then
what you just had a series of reasons
why you should be series of reasons why
this would be a good idea not just at
any time but now and for some reason it
did eventually it worked and I would
punish my child if they had done that
those freaks the presentation ended with
with let me go
well it didn't end with you probably
remember more about it than I do
well it doesn't end it ends with you
putting up the picture and it says Emma
Stone actress best was it best no no
first of all my name is Emily so there's
that okay no we didn't say you're gonna
win an Oscar why are we telling this
story
[Applause]
that's what I told the whole point is
crazy
I don't what it's quite crazy like
absolutely she's going somewhere and
it's not there oh well you want an Oscar
[Applause]
[Music]
you